foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 2005.
object class Xeno medium containment
difficulty and low threat
special containment procedures
contained scp-2005 instances are to be
contained in individual Faraday
insulated Electronics or vehicle lockers
depending on appropriate size and site
65 and restrained with straps attached
to the bottom top and rear wall of the
locker to prevent motion Earth's orbit
is to be monitored for possible
additional instances of scp-2005
following recovery data regarding the
probe is to be concealed via eser
protocol and researchers are to disable
and or remove any transmission equipment
present in the instance during initial
experimentation if possible
description
scp-2005 is a series of probes of
extraterrestrial origin designated
scp-2005-a to
scp-2005e these devices differ radically
in external design but their internal
systems transmission parameters and
other features indicate a common origin
scp-2005 instances record audio visual
and other data and transmit it via radio
to what is believed to be their Point of
Departure which researchers hypothesized
to be on or orbiting a planet or other
body in the Tea Garden star system
located approximately 12.5 light years
from Earth's sun see document 2005b
astronomical data the foundation has
disabled or removed transmission devices
from contained scp-2005 instances when
possible in 1992 a request was made for
funding to attempt to replicate
scp-2005a's coding for foundation use
this request was denied by the site
director as the substance cannot under
any circumstances
[Music]
scp-2005-a is a teardrop shaped probe
measuring 1.4 meters in diameter and
coated in a layer of pale green polymer
a sample removed during analysis was
demonstrated to be highly resistant to
temperature changes kinetic impact
chemical corrosion and other forms of
damage
the outer coning is capable of being
retracted in numerous places along the
body allowing for the use of a large
Central Camera the narrow section opens
to allow material to be absorbed into
the aperture where it is analyzed and
apparently disintegrated
scp-2005-a was recovered from an art
gallery By Her Majesty's Fellowship for
the study of Curiosities and fentis
magoria and Marseille in 1897 where it
had been modified and installed as part
of an upcoming Salon de refuse
exhibition following reports of
involvement from the new Avon conclus
Art Collective otherwise known as are we
cool yet
in 1986 advancements in computer science
since initial containment allowed
Foundation researchers to begin the
process of reverse engineering
scp-2005-a's storage drives although
information not recorded in human
languages has still not been deciphered
the majority of information recorded on
earth is printed materials with a
roughly equal ratio of fiction and
non-fiction sources notably a large
collection of works of H.D Wells and
Jules Verne the following is a
transcription of the original
containment document created by the asci
for
scp-2005-b original audio recorded in
1939.
description
scp-2005b is disguised as a zeppelin it
measures about six feet at its longest
Point its outer facade is made of copper
a fabric that looks like canvas but
seems to be some sort of exotic nylon
and asbestos now looking inside however
we find large torn scraps of
invulnerable plastic similar to the
coating of
scp-2005 which is now called
scp-2005a to match this new arrival it
seems to have shed its skin at some
point the balloon section of the craft
is filled with Machinery the guts of the
thing are similar to
scp-2005as and equally Beyond human
advancement on the outside a system of
gears and levers protrudes from the
bottom which appear to control a series
of mechanical arms but on closer
examination the arms seem to be powered
through electricity or a completely
exotic power system the purpose of the
years is unknown
the mechanical appendages extending
downward from the machine include
mechanical hands wearing gloves made of
white plastic a secondary microphone and
what looks like other recording
equipment scissors a comb and a mop when
deploying the mop it holds the mop's
handle with an extended grasping tool in
a manner that somewhat emulates human
use when it is indoors and a human
enters visual proximity
scp-2005b deploys its mop and carries
out cleaning behavior until the human
exits the room or faces away from the
machine
scp-2005b can also provide haircuts on
request but it is totally incompetent at
the task and collects the scraps of hair
scp-2005b was discovered in Boston in
May of 1939. two years after initial
tracking of a fast-moving cigar-shaped
aerial object began in the vicinity of
nante in France eyewitness reports
indicate that it flew at varying
altitudes at speeds of up to 30 miles
per hour sometimes darting around like a
bird and entered buildings to literally
consume books and other printed media by
pulling them up to itself Foundation
containment agents managed to trap it in
a reinforced reading room
dictated by Dr Stephen bester
thank you
in 1945
scp-2005-b was lost due to the defection
of area 12 to a group which was known to
the foundation as cockmang Hong Chao or
the chaos Insurgency
scp-2005b and scp-2005-d see below were
returned as part of the Sydney Accord of
2022 a non-aggression treaty signed by
the SCP Foundation and the Insurgency
which had been renamed the Pacific
Storage trust it is unknown whether the
trust was able to reverse engineer or
otherwise replicate any component of
either object
scp-2005-c is a humanoid automaton the
object is encased in a self-pressurizing
spacesuit made of a thick highly
reflective foil believed to be a
derivative of the material coding of
scp-2005-a except colored bright red
with a vertical white stripe on each
side of the suit's limbs the chest opens
outward to reveal that most of the Torso
and backpack are a single compartment as
present in previous versions of scp-2005
the transparent face covering visor has
not been analyzed due to concerns of
shattering it
[Music]
scp-2005c's head is made with the same
Chrome substance and superficially
resembles a humans with a highly
detailed angular mouth and jaw and
eye-shaped ovals the object will reply
to prompts in English French and Russian
with relevant pre-recorded messages in a
computerized Voice using the language in
which the prompt was made
The Machine's Palm contains a
retractable radio antenna when extended
it is capable of moving objects at a
distance without physical contact
powering electrical devices and
transmitting pre-recorded messages
directly to radios television sets and
certain metal objects these radio beams
have no apparent maximum range and cause
significant Communications interference
in the area
excerpt interview 2005c transcript
note the full interview is available in
the attached document 2005 C2 full
interview transcript
1968 1422
where you come from
foreign
[Applause]
welcome
disarmed and approaches the local
library
what is your purpose here the mouse dry
with the fullness of creation key to
simulation of a billion Hearts before
him tastes truth justice and the
American way as he Longs with tight
anticipation for the bookstore or
magazines found closest to your house
why do you care about books he's doing
the only possible to immense Evolution
the Wheeling before the thoughts of a
generation like sandpaper on fire but he
needed to know the future and the
prognosis which left tigerishly to like
the Lions of Daniel before him was
forwarding
who created you personally curse word
from withhold from a distance of those
not dissimilar world
seeking the line of truth but peace
the peace and wisdom in their hearts as
they were blood of great minds to read
the predictions
foreign
[Applause]
tell me about these predictions
Legends written does not which had not
yet come to pass
and while those who had fallen before
him and used in them as a stopcap
measure gay compensation
smooth and Martini to account for these
delays in transit if you let him blend
in with these cities of mankind years
away
but there was priceless there are the
Brilliance of your sooth Sayers this
Challenge and so quickly in the fall of
time
Who are the soothsayers repeats the
previous statement all right
of Transit again repeats the previous
statement
end log
researchers believe that
scp-2005c is describing the process by
which it was designed according to the
automaton's testimony reproduced here
probe instances are made to blend in
with populated areas in order to better
observe humanity and explore human
civilization however the
Extraterrestrial manufacturer's distance
from Earth means that any data will take
several decades to reach their Planet as
the species is not developed faster than
light transport or communication
thus scp-2005 instances have been
designed not only to take in data about
Humanity but to specifically Target
information which predicts how human
civilization will develop in the future
in the process the manufacturing species
has misinterpreted science fiction
writing as literal factual description
of our future this speculation was
corroborated in 2023 when
scp-2005b's hard drive was recovered and
stored English texts were decrypted the
apparatus had recorded film Archives of
Flash Gordon and Fritz Lang's Metropolis
among other works
scp-2005-c was recovered from a military
base in California in 1968 with the
cooperation of the US Army according to
reports it was being kept as a mascot of
sorts by a group of religious youths who
were camped in front of a NASA base the
loiters were arrested by military police
for causing a disturbance and
interfering with military Communications
presumably as a result of
scp-2005-c's activity
the group was questioned individually
and detained on suspicion of being
communist spies after researching the
group was believed to have ties to a
Russian socialist organization called
the bratzfo Pietro ninspha a radical
group whose stated goal is the creation
of a fifth International workers union
and were arrested on several charges
scp-2005-c was then retrieved for
containment any direct connection
between
scp-2005c and
scp-2573 or what was then termed the
northern fifth church is unknown
scp-2005-d is an autonomous
extraterrestrial aircraft of similar
composition and structure to the three
probes previously designated
scp-2005. the craft is an oblate
spheroid with a structure that consists
of eight sealed cylindrical Chambers
these ponds are arranged at a downward
slant in a circular pattern around a
central core
each chamber has a door along the top
which opens when effort is exerted in
any direction upon its luminescent
yellow handle the central core contains
the operational systems of the machine
recording equipment extends from the
bottom of the core as well as grasping
tools scanners that indicate temperature
and other environmental variables a
geiger counter an array of radiation
cleaning devices and a tube which
dispenses nutrient cubes
in this article nutrient cubes is the
term used for the homogeneous sterile
cubes which are continuously internally
generated by
scp-2005-d these 25 gram Green Tinted
blocks contain a mixture of synthetic
proteins fats and carbohydrates that is
suitable for long-term human consumption
a test subject reported that nutrient
cubes taste like mint and salad dressing
ugh
when scp-2005-d encounters a human it
lowers itself to the human's eye level
begins to emit a low hump and tilts so
that one chamber is vertically upright
and facing the human the handle of the
facing chamber then begins to Glow with
an intermittent pulsing pattern if the
human does not grasp the door handle
scp-2005d will follow the human in this
position for an average of 15 minutes
before abandoning the procedure the
machine will also dispense nutrient
cubes and offer them to the human at
various stages in this process
if the human enters the interior of the
chamber the door is sealed and locked
while the external Geiger
counteractivates
scp-2000d will then travel to the
nearest populated location deploy its
radiation absorbing modules to
decontaminate the area and then eject
the human
it contains a padded surface with
protrusions at the top and bottom that
act as headrest and foothold
respectively the chamber's interior is
shielded against radiation and
electromagnetism beyond the protection
offered by the polymer coating and is
sealed airtight when the door is closed
it contains numerous life support
systems as well as additional features
that appear to have been installed for
Comfort including a set of sliding
switches whose only purpose seems to be
the pitch volume and interval controls
for a constant humming noise and a
device containing a canister of
synthetic oil that infuses the purified
air with the scent of roasted pork
while a human is inside a chamber a
projector will periodically present
messages on the interior of the door at
head level these include statements such
as this is safe water is provided and
you are almost a decontaminant questions
will also be provided these are followed
by the protrusion of an onboard
microphone toward the inhabitant for a
full report of statements and questions
provided during testing and answers
given by subjects consult document 2005
D4 message transcript examples include
who finally started it are you dying do
you have any books and would you like to
read
when the second question was asked in
testing a yes answer resulted in
scp-2005-d immediately ejecting the
subject from the bottom of his chamber
note authorization requests for testing
with dying subjects were denied in the
instance where the third question was
asked a slot opened in the inhabited
chamber which revealed a compartment the
words insert please hear were projected
in the last example the test subject was
instructed to answer yes and the
projector switched to an image of text
which was determined on later analysis
to be the Sirens of Titan a novel by
Kurt Vonnegut however the text was not
legible to the test subject due to the
extremely small typeface used in
projecting the novel in its entirety
scp-2005-d was initially recovered by
the Prometheus Labs Corporation circuit
1997 for reverse engineering by the
traditional method as opposed to the
type carried out by Prometheus Labs
using Axiom suspension drives and
apparently fed it information as
requested to pacify it following the
destruction of the facility which
contained it it transported itself to a
Pacific Storage truss facility within
the same region while carrying
Prometheus lab staff
the probe was provided to the foundation
during Sydney Accord proceedings upon
inspection it was found to have minimal
damage from exposure to Axiom suspension
drives unlike most equipment and
Personnel who were present during the
Scranton event this has been attributed
to both the relatively short time spent
in Prometheus Labs containment and to
the probe's polymer coating according to
Declassified Pacific Storage trust
documentation plants had been drawn for
the use of
scp-2005-d's nutrient Cube technology by
a wing of the trust known as the Mana
charitable Foundation but these were
scrapped before implementation due to
unspecified catastrophe
scp-2005e is an extraterrestrial
research device
scp-2005e technology broadcast
parameters and composition are similar
to that of
scp-2005-d and fully described in the
attached document 2005 E1 material
analysis
scp-2005e is comprised of a series of
interlocked segments of various widths
and lengths with an ovoid central
processing core H is coated on the
underside with dermic interaction points
designed to interface with the human
neurological system without puncturing
the skin when
scp-2005e encounters a human it
broadcasts a computerized voice which
offers to act as a non-invasive
cybernetic implant in exchange for
harmless cerebral monitoring it then
requests that the subject turned to face
away from the probe so that it may rest
on the subject's back to interface with
him or her on several occasions in
testing once contact was made subjects
turning to run were considered by
scp-2005-a to have accepted
scp-2005e's primary neurological
interaction involves the recording of
thoughts and sense data it also provides
a thought activated heads-up display
which includes physiological data
chemical analysis based on smell and
taste readable texts from an internal
database of human fiction and
non-fiction books with one exception see
below and a camera function which stores
visual data for later viewing at an
average rate of 10 times per day the
display will present one or more
pictures or videos taken from previous
sense data in order to record the
subject's mental health and physical
reactions
this display is not compatible with
existing intracranial devices and
provides much less functionality due to
limited internet access although
scp-2005e appears to be capable of
network connection its bandwidth and
compatibility are severely restricted by
the modem cable required to do so and
use has reported to be extremely
unpleasant due to the noise level of the
dial-up tone
several display aspects are apparently
non-functional including a bullet's
remaining counter which has never
displayed an output other than zero zero
an indicator which claims to detect
whether the user is inside a dream or
simulation which has never displayed any
output other than a blue circle
scp-2005e was recovered from the Moon in
2042 where it had made contact with a
church belonging to the
Reconstructionist sect of Christianity
see archived files pertaining to the
Church of the broken God recovery was
designated a blue clearance semi-public
event due to the presence of U.S
president w w solenoid who is attending
a worship service at the time
a text file is present in scp-200a's
data storage which unlike others that
have been loaded is not of human origin
in the display's browsing menu it is
titled message to those who disable
transmitters send
the text reads as follows
recorded data of events indicates that
majority developments not fully planned
or accounted for discrepancy Priority
One retention of planetary civilization
if transmitters have been disabled
reinstalled if capable record response
do you not understand yourselves
please clarify
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Big sip
zargura
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
disk luzire 420
that loser
heroin sick
fire of prime
Indy versus the world
Spencer are doing
rubbish bin 69.
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Lam k
agnar
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you